son bureau du kremlin que vladimir
poutine dialogue avec emmanuel macron un
entretien téléphonique pour tenter de
désamorcer la crise la balle est dans le
camp russe avait dit un peu plus tôt
jean yves le drian
routine de dire s'il veut la
confrontation s'il veut la concertation
ou confrontation une concertation nous
sommes prêts la concertation encore
faut-il être deux pour le faire ce midi
moscou tente de rassurer sur ses
intentions si cela dépend de la russie
il n'y aura pas de guerre
nous ne voulons pas de guerre mais nous
ne permettrons pas non plus que nos
intérêts soient violés de manière
flagrante que nous intérêt soit ignorée
difficile de décrypter les intentions de
la russie qui refusent que l'ukraine
puisse un jour rejoindre l'otan en
attendant moscou poursuit ces grandes
manoeuvres un déploiement spectaculaire
sur terre en mer
mais aussi dans le ciel
l'ukraine plus que jamais prise en étau
sur son sol les séparatistes pro-russes
du donbass
côté russe cent mille soldats aux
frontières de l'ukraine et des missiles
déployés en biélorussie en réponse
l'otan a massé des troupes dans six pays
et activer des bases aériennes et
antimissile
washington enfin mis en alerte et 8500
soldats
chaque camp bande ses muscles mais la
porte de la diplomatie reste ouverte